VIDEO GAME REPAIRMAN: Brand
spanking new.
RICK: I can't believe that
piece of junk turned into this.
I love stuff like this.
THE OLD MAN: That's the most
beautiful thing I ever seen.
[laughter]
BOB: Do you get it?
COREY: Yeah, I get it.
[music playing]
RICK: Bob sold me a
spark plug cleaner
from the 1930s that was
in really rough shape,
and then I paid
him to restore it.
Hey, you want to see what
a champion this guy is?
COREY: It's
definitely cool, Bob.
RICK: The Alfred Champion Spark
Plug Company and this champion
restored it.
[laughter]
Do you get it?
Yeah, I get it.
Had to mix up
this color special.
It was hard to mix up.
And then media blasted it,
did all the body work on here.
This piece was missing,
if you remember,
so I made one out of steel.
Plus, all these graphics
here are hand-painted.
This is aluminum.
So when I painted it, I
scratched through the lettering
so it would show
up in the aluminum.
COREY: I mean, it looks awesome.
I have no doubt in my
mind we can sell it.
But listening to this guy say
"champion" is going to kill me.
[laughter]
RICK: When I gave
this gas pump to Rick,
it was virtually worthless.
Now it's all finished,
and Rick told me
I wouldn't even recognize it.
I'm going to see what I got.
Holy [bleep].
That is nice.
That is cool.
A little different than
when you saw it before, huh?
Yeah, it's way different.
RICK (VOICEOVER): When
I saw the gas pump,
it was just unbelievable.
And I couldn't believe
it was the same pump.
All this trim up here
was all painted and pitted,
so we ended up
repolishing all that.
Put your new glasses in here.
Most of the parts on this
thing are all original.
The only ones that
are not original
is this is a reproduction
plate, and this
is a reproduction globe.
Everything else is
totally original on it.
RICK: How much did
it cost me to fix it?
Right around 2,500.
RICK (VOICEOVER): That
gas pump is a beauty.
It really is.
It's something I really
want to bring home.
I love stuff like this.
I would just love gas to
be $0.32 a gallon again.
Yeah, you and me both.
[cash register ringing]
COREY: A few days
ago, me and Chum
dropped the Pac-Man machine
off to get repaired.
I really hope it's working
because if it's not,
we're going to lose money on it.
Nice to see you again.
See ya.
The top looked horrible
when I brought it in, man.
Is this brand new, or were you
able to fix the old one, or--
VIDEO GAME REPAIRMAN:
Brand spanking new.
But that's just the
cosmetic artwork to it.
Back in the day, people were
actually able to hack the board
and take a Pac-Man and
make it a Ms. Pac-Man
because Ms. Pac-Man
was far more popular.
And so we had to convert
it back to a Pac-Man.
So what was the total
cost after all is said
and done fixing this thing?
Well we're looking at about
350, right where I said before.
What do you think
we can get out of it?
I think you should be able
to get an easy $1,000 to $1,200
for it.
- OK.
CHUMLEE: Well he's gonna need
to improve before he plays me.
I don't even know if you're
gonna pass the first level.
[pac-man dying music]
[cash register ringing]
A few weeks ago, I brought
my sweet 1955 barber chair
to my buddy Rick
to get fixed up,
and now I'm on my
way to pick it up.
Whoa.
I can't believe that piece
of junk turned into this.
Oh, it looks great.
RICK DALE: Believe it or not,
this has over 200 pieces.
We had to take half
the pieces and send
them to the nickel plating
shop to get them nickel plated.
And then we had to take the
upholstery and send it all out
to get upholstered.
And then we painted the base.
RICK: Did you fix
all the hydraulics?
RICK DALE: Yeah, all the
hydraulics got redone.
RICK: Was there a
lot of hair in there?
Yeah, there was tons.
You want some?
Yeah.
I thought it was yours.
So the big question-- how
much this thing cost me?
Well to do all
the nickel plating
and the leather and the base,
it's going to be $2,500.
OK.
So what do you think
I can get out of it?
You should have no problem
getting $6,500 for this chair.
All right, sounds
like a deal to me.
Well try it out.
[grunting]
Oh yeah.
God, I miss my hair.
[cash register ringing]
Months ago, I called
a couple of buddies
who are great at picking stuff.
But I might have
gone a little bit
overboard buying a '57 Chevy
for my dad's 70th birthday.
Frank and Mike
really came through.
Rick Dale and the
Count have been working
overtime to get it restored.
And today's the day.
I just hope it's ready.
I cannot wait to see his face.
Dammit, Rick.
We just got to pick
something up real quick.
ALL: SURPRISE!
[cheering]
Oh my god.
Happy birthday.
It's a '57 Chevy 150.
That is one beautiful car.
That's the most beautiful
thing I ever seen.
You have no idea what a
challenge this thing was,
to make a car look like this.
I'll see you guys bright
and early tomorrow morning.
But we got cake for you.
Screw the cake.
[applause]
MAN: Woo!
THE OLD MAN (VOICEOVER):
Rick is a great son,
but I was expecting
chicken wings.
He can be a cheap SOB.